hey youtubers is Charlie this week for
my Game of Thrones video I wanted to
talk all about the sand snakes if you
saw my video last week I explained some
of the changes that the show is making
to the books today I'm gonna talk about
all eight of them the eight bastard
daughters of Oberyn Martell from various
women the show is only doing three of
them though when I get to the five that
we're cut out I'll just also talk about
why I think that they chose not to use
them on the show and what I think it
means for the story in season five
versus the books there were also some
big spoilers that posted four specific
characters as well as a really notable
scene that I'll explain whenever I get
to the spoiler portion of the video if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do weekly Game of Thrones videos
I even do a weekly book giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so if
you've never heard of the sand snakes
their Oberyn and daughters oldest to
youngest they are Obara Nymeria tyene
Sorella Elia Oh Bella Daria
and Larissa the youngest of the four
belonging to ilaria the woman that you
saw Oberyn with in season four played by
Indira Varma we're not gonna meet any of
the other sand snakes mothers but I'll
talk about them whenever I'm talking
about each of the characters the show is
only focusing on Obara Nymeria and tyene
the oldest ones so because most of you
probably haven't read the books I'm
gonna talk about all of them oldest to
youngest and then I'll save the spoilery
stuff for the end and also talk about
some cool theories about winds of winter
George RR Martin's did explain a
comic-con that all of the sand snakes
will have really big roles in that book
so first off is Obara sand she's the
oldest she's being played by Keesha
Castle Hughes on the show if you look at
the fan art version of her from the card
game
she looks very different I know this
will bug some of the book readers but
the show does this all the time for
instance use and in the book is supposed
to look like Jabba the Hutt and on the
show this is what the actor playing him
looks like it's just another day in
television
Keisha castle Hughes is a great actress
so I'm glad that they cast her I think
she will go to the same type of fight
training that they gave to Pedro Pascal
that they actually posted some cool
videos of him learning to use the weapon
Obara in the books always reminded me of
a older version of Brienne more
militaristic and cunning so she is also
going to be very handy with a spear
regardless of the way the show treats
her backstory ho borrows mother was just
a common from Old Town her name is
never mentioned but whenever Obara was
old enough
Oberyn came to claim her he threw
spear down at her feet in Escobar to
choose between it and her mother and she
chose the spear so it gives you an idea
of what kind of life she prefers as an
adult her weapons of choice are the
signature spear that you saw Oberyn used
during his fight with the mountain a
whip and a round shield whenever we
first meet her in book 4 she's described
as being about thirty years old and Big
Bone meaning she looks kind of like
Brienne she's a warrior she's a big
fighter which is why I was a little
surprised when they cast Kisha Castle
Hughes she probably just blew them away
in the casting session so I am
optimistic all the sand snakes have very
hot tempers but because Obara has lived
such a martial life she prefers the
military life she respects Authority
that's a big contrast to her half-sister
princess Arianne but the shows not doing
her so it's not a big deal I'll wait
till I get to the spoiler session to
talk a little bit how about how I think
this show is gonna change over Aras
character but moving on sans sake number
two is Nymeria she's being played by
Jessica Henrik on the show she's about
five years younger than Obara and her
mother was a highborn woman from
volantis that's actually one of the free
cities from the Eastern continent it's
south of Braavos but it's still really
far away from slavers Bay where Daenerys
is on the show in the book she's
described as looking more like what
you'd expect a highborn person to look
like you know very pale skin very
beautiful very high cheekbones imagine a
more sinister version of Sansa which is
kind of funny because Sansa just dyed
her hair black like my Miriah at the end
of season 4 maybe she'll take up daggers
too just to explain that marries weapon
of choice is the dagger she carries
several honor though because it's HBO
and Dan and Dave got really salacious
with oberyn's bisexuality they'll
probably show Nymeria as bisexual - it's
implied in book 4 that she's a lesbian
but I don't think that she or Oprah and
thought of it in those terms I think
that they both really just liked having
sex with whoever cut their eye and
sometimes it was men sometimes it was
women if you're a fan of Torchwood think
of it like Captain Jack anything that
moves her temper is a little bit worse
than no borrows and because she's
highborn she has a little less respect
for authority on the show you could
probably expect her reaction to oberyn's
death to be the craziest of all the sand
snakes again there's some other
interesting things that I think the
show's gonna do with her that I'll
mention during the spoilers section
moving on to San snake number three
tying she's being played by Roosevelt
sellers on the show in the book she
reminds me a lot of Aria if the Starks
had not been split up Taine's the
daughter of a set
implied that she's from Highgarden we
never find out what her mother's name is
either but there are some theories that
I'll explain in a second they're
actually pretty interesting in the books
it doesn't say that she's from
Highgarden it just implies that princess
Aryan and some other sand snakes go to
visit her mother in that area in order
to get there they had to cross the
Mandor and that's the river that flows
through the reach where Highgarden is
there was also this incident later when
Titan and Arian plotted to marry Aryan
to Willis Tyrell that's Loras his older
brother he's the heir to Highgarden but
he's a with a bad leg it's not
something the show's gonna deal with
because the show isn't doing Arianne but
I think it's just a nice coincidence
because Aryans father Prince Tran is
also crippled tieying's weapon of choice
is poisons just like her father Oberyn
the show paid homage to it during
turians trial whenever we saw that kid
coding over and spear and poison before
the fight so here's a really cool theory
about tieying's mother it just ties her
to another major house in Westeros the
two best theories that I've seen are
septa l'amour and one of the wayne woods
parentage and bloodlines and Game of
Thrones is very complicated everyone is
a complete in the best possible
way of course there are callous people
on the show that are closely related to
other big characters from other great
houses without knowing it it's just
because everyone's parents were every
bit the horse that Cersei Jaime and all
the younger people are right now so do
not be surprised if you find out that
certain characters on the show are
related to each other even if they're
from other houses the reason that tyene
might be a heir to the great house is
because she might be the granddaughter
of Alice Aaron and Ella Swain would the
show didn't really go into those
characters but Alice is the sister of
Jon Arryn father of Robin who we have
met the septa L'Amour theory is a bit
more conjecture there's more evidence
for the waynwood theory so all this
evidence for the waynwood theory comes
from feast for crows chapter 41 or
Elaine - depending on which copy of the
book you're reading the wayne woods had
two daughters that both became SEPTA's
one of those daughters was seduced by a
saul sword and had a child it's possible
that that sell sword was really Oberyn
Martell and the win was just covered
enough to avoid a scandal Tang would
have been born around the time that Elia
Martell was betrothed to Rhaegar
Targaryen so it's possible that to avoid
a scandal with Dorne and the crown the
Wayne woods covered up the true identity
of the saw sword and said that the child
died it's not ironclad evidence or
anything but
is one of eight daughters and her
supposed grandmother Alice Aaron is one
of eight daughters it could just be a
coincidence but George our Mardan could
have intended for us to draw that
conclusion and also if you have read the
books and you know who Harry Harding is
he's a proven Erin and he and tyene both
have the same signature dimples on their
face it's not a theory that I think is
gonna bear any fruit on the show it's
just a really interesting subplot in the
books in real life history things like
this happened all the time people from
noble families had bastards with other
prominent families and they covered it
up just to avoid a scandal but here's a
really crazy tinfoil theory what if
oberyn martell was whoring himself out
all over the world as part of some sort
of long con plan like he intentionally
created heirs connected to specific
major powers in the East in major houses
in Westeros usually alliances are made
with marriage and children but they're
all bastards so I don't think that's
what was really going on I think he was
just a man-whore it's just fun to think
that he intentionally created a Dornish
heir to the Eyrie which is a really big
powerful area in Westeros tane is the
last sand snake that the show is doing
but the other five are still really
interesting Sorrell is the next sand
snake her mother was a trader from the
Summer Isles
we don't hear what her mother's name is
but we do know that she is the captain
of a ship called the feathered kiss so
in case you forgot the Summer Isles is
where grey worm is supposed to be from
so Sorella would had the same dark skin
as he does there is a really cool theory
from book 4 that serella is secretly
masquerading as a character named Alerus
in old town mostly because Alerus is
Sorella
spelled backwards but because a lot of
you probably haven't read book 4 yet I
won't talk about her character too much
just because Alerus that mystery
character crosses paths with people on
the show the reason that they probably
didn't cast around the show is because
her part is really small and she doesn't
really show up till the end of book 4
but because she does cross paths with
main characters that are on the show
right now
they might cast her for season 6 or 7
but moving on to four daughters of a
Laureus and so the rest of the sand
snakes all belonged to the same woman
ilaria the woman we met on the show
ilaria is a bastard like Jon Snow but
she is the daughter of a noble house her
father is Lord Harmon Oller their
Bannerman to the Martell so she and her
children do descend from royalty but
they are still named as bastards the
reason the show isn't doing her children
is because they have even smaller parts
in books four and five Elia is the
oldest she's about 14 which makes
pretty close to Arya's age she's
supposed to have a big storyline with
Arianne Martell and wins a winter though
so you can look forward to that next
Isabella she's about 12
then there's Daria she's about eight and
Larissa she's the youngest sand snake
she's about seven so real quick
interesting side note about all areas
father Lord Harmon he ended up
travelling to King's Landing for Joffrey
Marjorie's wedding but the show did not
cast him they cut him out but in the
books he was there for the purple
wedding he was there when it all went
down so now let's talk a little bit
about the show and what it might be
changing about some of these characters
mostly the story's gonna draw from books
for some from book 5 for some characters
the show is probably going to be
changing Obara Nymeria and tyene to give
them bigger parts than what they had in
the books if anything they'll just take
Arianne's story and give it to them so
here's where I need to get into
specifics from book 4 so careful for
spoilers if you haven't read it yet just
skip forward in the video like 45
seconds or if you don't care about
spoilers and don't worry but always just
a second okay everybody ready here we go
so remember in the book Arian wants to
rally support for marcela to take the
Iron Throne of all the characters
directly involved in that plot only
Marcela coda Obara tyene Nymeria and
Prince Doran have been cast also on the
other side of that equation there was a
casting sheet that leaked that put some
kings landing characters in Dorne when
they weren't there in the books
it showed Jaime and Bronn having a
really big scene in dorm probably a
battle scene it's a vast departure from
the books but here's what I think that
they're gonna be doing they'll still do
the marcela rebellion plot the ply just
expanded and give Myrcella a bigger role
that's probably why they recast the
actor they probably just felt that Amy
Richardson wasn't right for the expanded
part that they had written Nell tiger
free is gonna be the new Marcella they
did the same thing with Tommen so it's
not a new thing Game of Thrones recast
actors all the time so what they'll
probably do is the price swap the big
battle with the dark star for Jaime and
Bronn I don't think they're gonna chop
off from Ursula's ear they didn't chop
off Tyrians nose after Blackwater but
the big oh fight will still totally
go down they'll just subtract Eretz oak
heart and the dark start and add Jaime
and Bronn that does raise a whole lot of
questions about Jaime's whereabouts in
book 4 just because he's somewhere
totally different in the books but it
makes sense that the show would narrow
its focus to Dorne I still think that
Nymeria and tyene are gonna head
to King's Landing by the end of the
season and we'll see the crossover with
the high Sparrow being played by
Jonathan Pryce and just addressed there
were some pictures from a very big scene
being filmed at a bullring in Spain it's
a little bit funny because there's the
real-life controversy over them filming
in a live bullfighting ring that kind of
parallels the in book controversy of the
fighting pits it'll be a nice meta
situation for people that have read the
books and know what's going on what was
reported was is they were filming a
scene in a really big bullring with
actual Bulls in a shitload of extras I'm
gonna save that for a future video but
if you have read the books you totally
know what that scene is so get excited
and please use spoiler tags if you're
gonna comment about it in the comments
so in related news my next bonus video
is gonna be all about the faceless men I
know you guys have been requesting it
for a long time so be sure to subscribe
to get it
I'm also gonna be doing a Q&A video just
because I'm certainly have a little bit
extra time I got one more week left at
my job I'm so happy I put my job awhile
ago but I still have like the rest of
this week to go but in the meantime
click here to learn about some of the
big changes that they're making in
season 5 from the books and click here
to learn all about the golden company
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
[Music]
you